Hi everyone, today's video is made possible
by audible. Use our link audible.com/psych2go
Or text psych2go to 500-500
To get a free book, and two audible originals
And a 30-day trial.
Do you ever wonder
about how you turned out the way you are? Or why some
adults are more uptight than others while
others are fun and delightful? As cliche
as it sounds, it all comes back to your childhood.
Depending on the households we grew up in, some of us
may cringe at the thought while others may look starry-eyed
as they grow nostalgic. Before we begin
with this video, we want to remind you that it's never
too late to change your future. Even if
certain past events put you in a stronger likelihood of outcomes.
Here are 8 ways your childhood
affects your lifestyle.
1) If your parents
were highly strict, you may grow up to be codependent.
Did you have an overbearing mother who picked out every outift
for you? Or an inflexible father who made you
practise more sports instead of hanging out with your friends?
Even if they mean well, or believe that they are doing what's best for
you, helicopter parenting has harmful side-effects.
A big one being that you are more likely to grow up
codependent. As an adult, you might rely
on your partner to take care of the chores or have trouble
adapting to work life.
2) If your parents have a broken marriage, it changes your romantic demands.
It's like Pam said from the office, when you're
a kid, you assume your parents are soulmates. But
unfortunately,
this isn't always the case.
Divorce rates are sky-rocketing in America, now up to
40-50% of married
couples are more likely to end up in a divorce.
If your parents separated, especially if the event happened during
your early childhood, studies show that you're prone to having
higher demands when it comes to romantic relationships.
You may expect your partner to show a higher degree
of morality, loyalty and compassion
so you can trust them better.
3) If your parents micromanaged you, you're more likely to develop
depression. OK, we've talked about codependency,
but depression is also a damaging
side-effect of authoritarian parenting.
When you grow up with parents who do all the
decision making for you, it makes you assume that you're not
competent enough to problem solve on your own.
Instead of listening to you and nurturing you to learn from your
mistakes, they often force decisions onto you.
Even ones that make you unhappy.
This can lead to feelings of worthlessness, and low self-esteem
which follow you into adulthood,
manifesting into depression.
4) If your parents watched TV with you when you were a toddler
instead of reading to you, it can suppress
your communication skills. We always see
those commercials of mothers reading to their babies, but this
advertisment actually has value! It turns
out that if your parents expose you to more television
as a toddler instead of flipping through books, this can
hinder your communication skills. Studies
have shown that when a mother and child watch TV together,
the mother makes fewer comments to the child whereas
if she reads to her child, it promotes
the child to ask questions, and a higher response rate from the mother.
5) If you copied your parents a lot,
you're more likely to be open to other cultures.
Did you often imitate your parents growing up? Even if
the actions didn't always make sense, you knew that
they had some sort of purpose. Researchers had an adult show
a child how to open a box with sticks.
Even though it's more practical to use their fingers,
when children imitate the behaviours of their parents, their more
likely to adapt to cultural norms. That's because
culture beliefs and customs may not always been seen
as practical and can even be outdated, but when the individual
is open to learning them,
they also have the ability to be more culturally aware.
6) If you were spanked as a child, you may become sneakier
as an adult. In some countries, it is now illegal
to spank your child because it's seen as physical abuse.
Depending on the severity of spanking, it has harmful
side-effects ranging from academic problems
to health ones, such as dying at a younger age of cancer,
heart diseases and respiratory diseases.
But, did you know that you also more prone to being
a sneaky adult? Author Daniel Pink
states that trying to influence a child's behaviour
by offering rewards and punishment does not always result
in the desired behaviour. In fact, children
who were spanked may work harder to avoid being punished.
7) If your parents have a drug or alcohol
addiction, you're susceptible to perfectionism.
Do you know someone who is serious, has a good work ethic,
and is bit of a perfectionist?
Chances are they might have grown up being a parent to their own
parents. When a child has parents who are alcoholics
or drug addicts, they never had the
opportunites to let loose and have fun.
Instead, they had to grow up faster than the
other children and take care of household responsibilities.
On the other hand, some children may adopt the habits
of their parents which can
manifest into depression, anxiety, and feelings of worthlessness
8) If you have a close relationship
with your father, you're more likely to enter
healthier relationships. We've all probably
heard of the term "Daddy Issues" when someone
grew up without a father around. Unfortunately, research
only continues to show it's true.
One study
examined the quality of father-child relationships among 3
groups. Orphans, children of divorced
parents, and children in stable families.
Results showed that the children,
whether they were male or female, with the close
relationship with their father was more common than those who didn't.
When we are able to love our
parents and learn to be patient with them, we are more likely
to do the same for our romantic partners.
Could listening make you a better person? There's never been
a better time to start listening on audible. With audible,
you get access to an unbeatable selection of audiobooks,
including bestsellers, motivation,
mysteries, thrillers, memoirs, and more.
Audible has the largest selection of audiobooks on the planet.
And now, with audible originals, the selection has gotten
even more custom, with content made for members.
Right now, we're reading "Work Stronger:
Habits For More Energy, Less Stress, And Higher Performance
At Work" by Pete Leibman. The author,
being a psychology major himself, really taps into the psychological
aspects of how strong your habits form to help us
be more productive. Audible members
can choose 3 titles every month, one audiobook,
and two audible originals you can't hear anywhere else.
Listen on any device, anytime, anywhere.
At home, at the gym, on your commute,
or just on the go. You'll also enjoy easy
audiobook exchanges, rollover credits, and an
audiobook library you keep forever, even if you cancel!
Audible, the most inspiring minds,
the most compelling stories. The best place to listen.
Get started with a 30-day trial when you go to audible.com/psych2go
Or text psych2go
to 500-500 and listen for a change!
That is A U D I B L E.com
/P S Y C H
2go or text psych2go
to 500-500. That is A U D I
B L E.com/
P S Y C H  2  G O
Or text P S Y C H 2go
to 500-500.
Which of these points do you relate to?
Did you know your childhood can also affect your lifestyle?
Check out our video here!
Thanks for watching!